il y à des phrases que madame la
présidente ne veux plus entendre comme
celle prononcée il ya quelques années
par le chef de son parti qui croyait
pourtant lui faire plaisir
il me dit nicole tu as vraiment bien
travaillé au parlement européen
maintenant tu as mérité un mandat
national
et qu'est-ce que choisir j'étais
abasourdi mais je visite comment tu me
dises à toi président d'un parti
européen mais tu devrais dire un député
à l'assemblée nationale tu as bien
travaillé à l'assemblée nationale
maintenant tu as mérité un mandat
européen depuis 15 ans nicole fontaine
peaufine son anglais à strasbourg et à
bruxelles
assidu convaincu elle souhaite montrer
l'exemple au parlement en direction
notamment de ses collègues français
réputés pour leur discrétion dans son
bureau nicole fontaine se montre très
déterminé lorsqu'elle évoque les futurs
rapports parlement commission
rien ne sera plus comme avant la
commission je dirais pas que la
commission est sous haute surveillance
ce serait peut-être pas une bonne
expression mais la commission sait
parfaitement que le parlement ne lui
pardonnera rien vous continuez tout
droit
vous avez vous une grande passerelle qui
mène
la tri dans sa grande maison il lui
arrive encore de se tromper de direction
mais son chemin elle la trace est depuis
quinze ans et son acharnement a fini par
pays
[Musique]